it was her first public comment since
leaving office last year tonight here in
berlin former german chancellor angela
merkel
described the war in ukraine as
quoting here a huge tragedy
she defended her policy towards russia
over her 16 years as chancellor she said
she does not blame herself
for the events that are unfolding now
but
she did admit
she says she asked herself if she could
have done more to prevent the war from
happening
here is part of what she had to say
about how the conflict has been
impacting her life
is
my retirement hasn't turned out quite
the way i'd expected
february 24th was a major turning point
and it's something i think about often
but if you're asking about my personal
feelings
i stepped down for my position as
chancellor by choice
and that's a nice feeling
i've started doing other things
and that also feels nice
but at heart i remain a political person
so at times like these i feel as worried
as many others do
all right let's go now to our chief
political editor michaela kufner she was
there listening to that
interview tonight nicola you know so
many people here in germany but around
the world they've been waiting for
angela merkel to break her silence since
retirement what did she have to say
well first of all she said it wasn't a
silence that after 16
years in office and six months without
making public statements isn't such a
long time she condemned this russian
aggression she also described ukraine as
a hostage in the standoff between
vladimir putin and the west that he was
attacking everything that western
liberal democracy
stands for and that he was attacking the
very foundations upon which a peaceful
togetherness rests she said that she
wanted to find a way
if if one cannot be friends with russia
at least of coexistence and that
diplomacy failing doesn't mean that one
shouldn't have tried now we're all
asking yourselves why she never picked
up the phone to vladimir putin let's
take a listen to what she had to say
about that
what i find particularly calming is that
if something were to happen something i
thought was being handled in entirely
the wrong way while there's any number
of people i could call but that's not
been necessary
so basically she's been saying she would
not call vladimir putin unless she was
asked by the current government who she
felt was doing were professionals she
described them as after all shots the
current chancellor was her vice
chancellor and that she didn't wouldn't
do anything unless being asked by him by
the government at the very least she
doesn't seem to see it as her role to
interfere and we also learned from her
who's been in parallel with vladimir
putin for way more than a decade in
office that her feeling was that the
only language he understands anyway
was deterrence and there she did admit
that one should should probably have
done more on the military side yeah when
she says one should have done more on
the military side i mean she's been
criticized for not
being tougher with putin while she was
in power for 16 years i mean did she
take any responsibility for
the threat to european security that we
now face
well um yes and no um she says yes of
course it was also her responsibility to
build an architecture that would contain
russia and that's what she felt she had
done um her sense was that by not
allowing and let's be very concrete here
ukraine to join nato earlier not
allowing that path towards nato that
former u.s president bush wanted for
instance and she put fear still feels
today and that's why she says she's
resting easy on this that she prevented
something terrible from happening
earlier and that at the very least the
minsk agreement after the annexation of
crimea in 2014 had bought ukraine time a
country which she describes as being a
very different country from seven years
ago and that it is much more of a stable
democracy and that partly is also why
vladimir putin sees it as such a threat
let's just take a listen to what she had
to say on that fundamental difference
between putin and her
it was clear that we had a big
disagreement
and our positions kept growing apart
for all intents and purposes
and looking back
we haven't been able to effectively put
an end to the cold war
there's always been the issue of russia
i don't agree with putin to make it
perfectly clear
but we've also not been able to forge a
security architecture that could have
kept this from happening
that's something to think about
and it's something historians will
certainly ponder
but i want to make it clear so that
there's no
misunderstanding there is no justifying
the attack on ukraine that took place on
february 24th
it is a brutal attack flying in the face
of human rights for which there is no
excuse
so clearly the german class is still
doing quite a lot of thinking on what
she could have done differently but not
really departing from that course that
she's taking towards vladimir putin yeah
michaela there are critics of the former
chancellor calling for a reckoning with
her legacy
do you think
tonight's interview there on stage will
will that
satisfy her critics
no clearly not um also and we know that
uh the ukrainian ambassador mel nick
kieran berlin contacted the interviewer
beforehand and the very question was why
didn't you allow us to join nato the
question he has for germany continuously
is why are you not sending more weapons
and i think that criticism won't stop
but what she did tonight is explain that
she did have a strategy to find a way of
coexistence and notably the lack of
european unity is something she felt was
in the way of having a much more stable
security architecture that could have
potentially contained russia
yeah and on that point she faced that
problem many many times that is for sure
our chief political editor mikhail
kufner tonight here in berlin michelle
thank you
all right i want to pull into the chief
europe correspondent at politico matthew
karnich he joins me from right here in
berlin tonight matthew it's good to see
you again
you've written in very clear and direct
language pointing the finger at angela
merkel and accusing her as being one of
putin's useful idiots while she was in
power
she took questions tonight for the first
time here
will her answers will they satisfy her
critics
i don't think so because i think what
she was trying to do this evening was
what some of us expected which was to
effectively defend her record which is
which is her right of course but if you
look back over the trajectory
of the 15 plus years that she was
chancellor you could see really a
pattern that i think someone in her
position really should have recognized
when it came to russia and when it came
to vladimir putin in particular
if you look at the invasion of georgia
in august of 2008 for example
followed by
the
annexation of crimea in 2014 the war in
dombas also of 2014
what russia did in syria and so forth
and throughout all of this miracle's
response was to really seek out putin
and to try and engage him through what
she called dialogue thinking that that
would be the answer to this aggression
and i think in retrospect
that policy clearly didn't work and as
merkel said today ultimately will be
historians who will
decide whether
her policies were the right ones or not
and i think you know that the
from my point of view that that the the
judgment is already pretty clear
but if she were to say i was wrong about
putin i should have pursued a different
policy
i do carry responsibility here i mean
what difference would that make for
the current government
i think it would make a huge difference
to be honest and let's be clear she
didn't say that tonight she said in fact
the opposite of that she said well this
was just sort of diplomacy and diplomacy
these are the sorts of things one needs
to do i think if she were to come
forward and say
i was wrong we were wrong from the
beginning and let's not forget that in
2008 before the invasion of georgia that
i mentioned in
may of 2008
merkel led a push to keep ukraine and
georgia out of nato this was something
that merkel really wanted to prevent and
it was something that the united states
of america at the time under george w
bush a president who's not really
thought well of in large
parts of
europe because of what happened in iraq
but but he was pushing for nato
enlargement to include ukraine and
georgia merkel was very much against
this and prevented it and there are a
lot of diplomats and other experts who
look at that decision now and say well
that really would have made a difference
today because if ukraine which was a
different country at the time obviously
but if they were under the
nuclear umbrella of nato this wouldn't
have happened so i think if she were to
have come forth today
and said look this was
a failed policy from the beginning it
would make a difference for the current
government because it's important to
remember this wasn't just miracles
policy this was german policy and it
wasn't controversial in germany it was
shared across the political landscape
for the past 15 years
there is
a a reckoning if you will with miracles
time in power i mean we're talking about
almost two decades here we're reporting
on it you're writing about it
but we still remain outliers i think
when we're talking about
the entirety of of the media but
especially here in germany will
tonight's comments her breaking her
silence if you will do you think that
that will maybe open up the reckoning
more so here
i think unfortunately within germany i
don't i don't think it will because i i
also feel that the
the media here especially the
public media which is so
influential in germany was complicit in
all of this because they bought this
line
basically
hook line and sinker
as as we'd say in the united states
that this was the right policy that
engaging putin was ultimately going to
bring about
the kind of
results that we wanted a partnership
that the west was seeking with him so i
don't think that her statements today
are going to make any difference on on
that score in fact i think it's going to
just harden this impression that this
was the right policy at the time it
didn't work out
but
you know this is the this was the the
sort of these were the cards we were
dealt at the time and we played them as
best we could
the chief europe correspondent at
politico matthew karnichini joining us
tonight interesting insights matthew we
appreciate it thank you
thank you